ich hoffe du siehst das video nicht ich
hoffe es klappt ist willkommen
es war schon egal herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ich hab ja irgendwann
letztens schon mal so ein altes video
von wirkt also ich hab ja irgendwie so
ein paar videos von mir gefallen die
sind schon etwas älter 12 13 14 oder
auch vom aussehen her acht allerdings
habe ich dir wieder rausgekramt und ich
habe da auch meine allererste parodie
gefunden früher habe ich wirklich
leidenschaftlich gerne parodien gemacht
noch irgendwelche geil songs also die
geilen songs waren danach hält nicht
mehr geil
allerdings habe ich es versucht und ich
fand das früher gar nicht mal so
schlecht aber ich glaube dass eben
angeguckt und es ist schlecht und auch
dieses thema in der parodie ne hätten
was meine eltern damals gesehen
ich glaube dir mich zu hause raus
geworfen ohne scheiß ich würde sagen wir
fangen direkt man ja bitte seid nicht so
gemein zu kleinen alex ich habe mich als
positiver entwickelt oder nicht und
nimmt das ganze bisher mit humor ist
schon scheiße aber ja so hat jeder mal
angefangen hab so leute das ist übrigens
eine parodie auf katy perry i kissed a
girl vielleicht kennen das ja noch ein
paar von euch das war früher war so voll
in glaube ich los geht's
st
gebt euch mal meine haare alter was ist
das denn wenn also diese mütze wann man
ist sie mit zu hässlich schreibt auch
genau jetzt mal in die kommentare wie
alt ich in dieser ersten szene aus sehe
ich jedoch nicht etwa aus 110 oder wie
sowieso mache ich das glaub ich wollte
einfach hin und her alles klar
wie schlecht man
und jetzt kommt der libdems
ich will den soundtrack kann ich sogar
noch nicht schlecht ich trinke ich mal
was ist das denn
trotz mich aber es kotzt mich an
ich frage mich ernsthaft max 4 fun ich
bin heute ist es zunächst nicht
leute ich muss dir mal kurz unterbrechen
das geht jetzt an meine mutter weiß wie
du siehst es tut mir sehr leid für
diesen song nimmt es nicht so ernst
ok mache weiter mit special effects
er gibt euch mal den pulli was ist das
einfach zweikämpfe übereinander und
zocken cars weiter das ist der chat und
da wird man fast genau alles klar
was die gerade hatte ich dann bh darüber
öffentlich stark machen ihr bitte bitte
bitte bitte
muss ich das noch weiter gucken ein
bisschen noch
ich zog einfach mit einer wert bedienung
dieser platz
und das passt auch nur der festung zum
songtext die sprung aus dem fenster und
kurz ins waschbecken
ich frage mich ernsthaft macht hier fand
er gibt sich aufheben
und jetzt kommt meine heftigste
tanzeinlage alter geht durch das
rutschen alter bräuche immer was ist das
hier drehten auch dieser effekt darüber
sehen ich weiß nicht was mit sony vegas
geschnitten aber nicht auch denken aber
man könnte denken movie maker gebt euch
mal diese tanzeinlagen wenn ihr eine
tanzakademie habt und mich haben wollt
schreibt einfach öffentlich kassel
und hier ist mein großes auto schütteln
ich sage gar nichts mehr ich bin einfach
nicht so viele leute mir fehlen die
worte ich weiß auch nicht so hat jeder
einmal in mainz hat eigentlich keine
angefangen außer ich ihr könnt ihr mal
in die kommentare schreiben was meint
ihr wie altmeister oder wie als ich aus
sehe ich aus wie 50 aus wie 8 oder doch
vielleicht schon gezählt schreibt in die
kommentare
und ja wenn ihr denkt ich habe mich
schon positiv entwickelt dann könnt ihr
auch gerne mal daumen nach oben da
lassen
dann sehe ich halt dass ich mich
schlimmer geht's eigentlich gar nicht
nur das wetter kacke wenn ich sie dir
nur 2000 gleich ob das schiff dem er
egal ob slapshot ins lamm alles
angewendet können wir gerne folgen fall
auf insider würde mich sehr freuen wir
uns links geht es auch weiter mit meinen
letzten ist nicht ja auf jeden fall
nochmal abchecken und ja wir sind uns
dann am nächsten sonntag wieder ich mit
schönen tag oder schön erinnerte zschau